This myth was popularized by an experiment
published in Nature in 1993 by the University
of California at Irvine.
In this study, they had 36 students listen
to 10 minutes of Mozart before taking a spatial
IQ test.
Their claim was that this increased the spatial
IQ score of the students by an average of
about 8 points, due to increasing performance
in specific types of spatial-temporal tasks.
Specifically, in their study, Rauscher, Shaw,
and Ky, gave participants one of three standard
tests concerning abstract spatial reasoning.
The subjects were exposed to three listening
conditions: silence, non-Mozart relaxing music,
and a sonata by Mozart.
Using the Stanford-Binet IQ test, they claimed
that listening to Mozart boosted the subjects
spatial IQ’s temporarily by 8-9 points over
the other two listening conditions.
There are a few problems with how this got
spun by the media.
First, the researchers claim was only that
it seemed to increase subject’s abilities
in certain spatial-temporal tasks.
They never said anything about increasing
ability anywhere else or in a person’s general
IQ, as their study was only on the effects
of Mozart on spatial-temporal reasoning.
The media of course proceeded to blow these
results out of proportion and say that this
study showed that listening to Mozart makes
you smarter in general, not just concerning
spatial tasks.
Yet another problem with the media and company’s
like Baby Genius’s portrayal of this is
that the results only showed an increase in
IQ for about 15 minutes.
There is no research to date that shows listening
to Mozart, or any other music, can boost IQ
permanently.
Now to the problems with the actual study
itself and their results.
First, they used a very small sample-size
in this study.
That should instantly be the first warning
flag that one should wait for further research
on this issue before jumping to conclusions
or taking the results as fact.
When you are dealing with small sample-sizes,
filtering out the noise from what is actually
happening is impossible in most cases.
With that in mind, it turns out, other researchers
have had very little success in replicating
the original results.
Several research projects have run the exact
same study, using the exact same methods and
implementation of the experiment and found
zero evidence of any “Mozart Effect”.
However, a few others have found some evidence
of a “Mozart Effect”.
So what’s going on here?
One team of researchers in 1999, made up of
Chistopher F. Chabris, Kenneth M. Steele et.
al., concluded, concerning the mythical Mozart
Effect, that “any cognitive enhancement
is small and does not reflect any change in
IQ or reasoning ability in general, but instead
derives entirely from performance on one specific
type of cognitive task and has a simple neuropsychological
explanation, called ‘enjoyment arousal’.”
“Enjoyment arousal” simply means that
if you are enjoying yourself, to some extent,
you will perform better at certain tasks you
are given.
On that note, another study showed that listening
to Mozart only boosted performance in spatial-temporal
tasks in those subjects who enjoy listening
to Mozart, which would explain the seemingly
random results various research projects have
come up with concerning this issue.
To further demonstrate that the cause was
“enjoyment arousal” and not Mozart, the
researchers read passages from Stephen King
novels to the subjects while they performed
their tasks.
The subjects who enjoyed Stephen King novels
showed a boost in their ability to perform
the tasks they were given at the same boost
level as the “Mozart Effect” subjects.
Those who did not enjoy Stephen King novels
showed no boost, similar to those who did
not enjoy Mozart music.
Further research by William Forde Thompson,
Gabriela Husain, and Glenn Schellenberg, in
2001, also backed up this claim.
In their study, they had subjects rate their
moods and energy levels while doing the specific
spatial tasks.
When listening to upbeat Mozart pieces, many
of the subjects reported their mood and energy
levels increased.
Those students who reported that increase
also scored better during this time.
They were also then tested with a more depressing
piece of music playing.
Not surprisingly, student’s moods and energy
levels went down and so did their results.
Once the results were calibrated with mood
and energy levels, it was found that it was
the mood and energy levels, not the music,
that was spurring the increased results.
Thus, it would seem that the results are entirely
based on whether the subject enjoys Mozart
or whatever it is they are listening to while
being tested, whether music, or simply someone
reading a Steven King novel to them.
So in the end, money spent on products like
much of the Baby Genius line, or the like,
by states and parents would be much better
spent on music lessons for kids; there is
a vast amount of research that conclusively
shows music lessons, particular for kids (the
younger the better), improves their ability
to concentrate; helps their self-confidence;
helps their coordination; and seems to boost
their intelligence as well, among other positive
developmental benefits to the brain.
Further, the boost is significantly higher
than even the most optimistic of the “Mozart
Effect” claims.
And best of all, these effects seem to last
for years, some of them for the entire life
of the individual and the improvements aren’t
subtle.
Indeed, one experiment showed that even just
eight months worth of regular piano lessons
on preschoolers will increase their spatial
reasoning IQ on average about 50%.
That’s not even including all the other
benefits; that’s just talking about the
spatial reasoning boost.
Of course, the reason people probably want
the Mozart Effect to be true, over learning
a musical instrument, is that listening to
Mozart is passive; it takes no work and is
generally enjoyable to listen to while doing
other things (hence the boost).
Learning an instrument and to play music is
hard and takes an amazing amount of work.
But in the end, if you want to maximize yours
or your children’s brain-related potential,
this particular brand of work has been proven
to pay off in spades.
Bonus Facts:
Interestingly, a recent study by Dr. Timo
Krings showed that pianists performed no better
than non-musicians at performing complex finger
movements.
However, when their brains were scanned during
these complex finger movements, it was found
that the pianists’ brains had significantly
less activity than the non-musicians, implying
the brains of the pianists were more efficiently
wired for making complex finger movements.
It is thought that learning to play music
increases the number of connections within
neurons in the brain, as well as creates new
pathways throughout the brain.
Indeed, MRIs of the brains of classically
trained musicians compared to non-musicians
showed a significantly enlarged nerve-fiber
tract (about 10-15% thicker) between the two
hemispheres of the brain.
This difference was particularly marked in
the musicians that had begun training before
seven years old.
It is thought this enlarged corpus callosum
improves motor skills and speeds up communication
between the two hemispheres of the brain.
Further studies have verified these claims
and also demonstrated an increase in connections
in the areas of the brain responsible for
emotion and memory.
The idea that listening to Mozart aids the
brain in some way actually goes all the way
back to the 1950s.
At that time, Alfred A. Tomatis, an ear, nose,
and throat doctor claimed that playing Mozart
to certain of his patients drastically aided
in fixing speech and auditory disorders, among
other things.
In 1991, he published a book on this subject
titled Pourquoi Mozart in which he explained
he felt that listening to Mozart helped retrain
the ear by providing varying frequencies for
the ear to perceive.
He also felt it promoted healing and aided
in the development of
the brain.